p42 here at some point in your life you
may have become frustrated with
modern-day lives the awful music long
work hours you can plane up everyone's
living through social media rather than
actually living
you may even foolishly believe that life
in the past was superior and that you
were born at the wrong time you may
think that life was simpler back then
less hectic and stressful tasks but in
reality how good or bad was
pre-industrial life before we have
machinery and modern medicine if we go
back to the Middle Ages or even all the
way back to the Roman Empire was life
ever any better than it is right now
let's take a dirty detour and flirt with
the filthy past to discover what it was
really like to live in the time of the
history book so why are dirty detour
into the past because ladies and
gentlemen the past was disgusting
utterly downright filthy cities were
also disease ridden the bigger city the
filthiest was humans are pretty
disgusting like that the biggest
contributor to this problem with
obviously the sewers or like off until
the last 300 or so years most cities
around the world relied on sewerage
systems no more advanced and throwing
your waste out of the window and hoping
it doesn't land on your wife's head some
fancier cities know like ancient Rome
and London had open sewers how opulence
of them to put it crudely open sewers
were no more than a river of [ __ ]
running past your front door very few
people had clean running water in the
past only the very wealthy whose water
was delivered through bled pipes which
gave them all heavy-metal poisoning
but wait a minute back up there was the
Romans credited with creating vast
underground sewerage system well yes but
they only built lows in the dwellings of
the upper classes they also built some
public toilets that led to underground
sewers but you have to share these with
hundreds of people some chose not to
despite the Romans having some
underground sewers we know from the
history books
that the majority of the lower-class in
ancient Rome and elsewhere still chose
to chuck their waste out of the window
onto the street it's just easier I guess
and in smaller towns and villages across
the world all throughout history dumping
your waste onto the streets or all over
your neighbor's cabbages has been the
standard way to dispose of it
interestingly emptying waste out of your
window was actually illegal in medieval
London
that didn't stop most people from doing
it though the recommended method of
waste disposal in London when actually
to dump it in the River Thames which is
where thousands of people also got their
drinking water from nice so what happens
to the endless waste piling up in the
streets
well sewage collectors known as
muckrakers would roam the street and
collect all the waste then take it to
local farmers and sell it as fertilizer
so next time you complain about your job
just remember you could be playing
Pokemon go with human feces for a living
and that's if you were lucky enough to
have a local shite shop boil some
historic accounts hell of streets that
were caked so deep in human waste that
stepping stones had to be built to
traverse them but that would only have
been a minor inconvenience to your
medieval self you would have been far
too busy trying to stay alive to care
about all the filth death and disease
was everywhere and almost every disease
out there was hideous and meant certain
death or if you are very lucky an
amputated limb without anesthesia of
course diseases such as leprosy diabetes
dysentery and measles were right and
there was no cure or treatments like we
have today in fact before the advent of
modern medicine if you manage to reach
the age of 40 and your face hadn't
fallen off yet then you were incredibly
looking but it wasn't actually all that
but contrary to popular belief peasants
in the Middle Ages did eat rather
well they weren't starved like the books
and films would have us believe the poor
actually ate a plentiful diet of
porridge bread meats
Jesus fruits and plenty of beer to wash
it all down with although to be fair the
beer did taste absolutely terrible
since Flemish hops hadn't been
introduced yet there was also
significantly less violence outside of
war than the movies portray medieval
taverns were actually relatively
civilized until of course you go and
steal somebody else's [ __ ] and you get
garroted so next time you complain about
modern day life and your lung work hours
at least you're not a slave for some
Lord or Emperor doing back-breaking work
seven days a week all the while trying
to avoid the plague and the myriad of
other fatal diseases out there and when
you walk home at night the ground you
tread upon is probably nicely paved and
relatively clean so just be thankful
because your street could be covered in
the collective works of your neighbors
bowels and on that cheery note thanks
for watching for this lake bed is
littered with hundreds of hundreds of
skeletal human remains then you could be
an extraordinarily intelligent person
possibly even genius level